hey youtubers it's Charlie so a bunch of
Walking Dead Season 5 stuff happening
right now I you all to submit questions
during my breakdown video of those
special and since then they've actually
announced the day that the comic-con
panel is gonna be happening and when
they're gonna air that trailer so mark
your calendars for Friday July 25th from
12:20 p.m. to 1:20 p.m. Pacific time
I'll be posting a full breakdown to that
after it happens so be sure to subscribe
to get that video there's also gonna be
a whole bunch of other stuff happening
that weekend so I'm gonna be doing some
specific Comic Con videos starting next
week also explain the special giveaways
I'm gonna be doing that week whenever I
start posting those so time to answer
some questions assume spoilers for
everything up to where we are on the
show right now everything through season
4 there's also not a lot of stuff that's
discussed from the comics aside from
what we've already talked about like the
hunters and father Gabriel and a few
behind the scenes images from stuff
they've been filming so here we go
everybody ready question number one Alex
asks what happened to terror sister is
she ever coming back so Lily was
actually killed during the governor's
attack in the aftermath of that yes she
did kill the governor that was the last
we saw of her on-screen it's implied
that she just didn't survive the walker
assault that came after the survivors
took off in different directions they
didn't really say flat-out whether or
not she died from some sort of wound she
received or if she shot herself or died
some other way based on the look in her
eyes as she shot the governor I'm
assuming that she shot herself her
daughter was dead and the man she
trusted turn out to be a complete lie
had Tara been there she might have saved
Lily but she wasn't so I think that Lily
just didn't have anything to live for
anymore and just wanted it all to be
over that's just my interpretation but I
just read it as her killing herself
question number two Dominic asks once
the survivors escape terminus what do
you think that they're gonna do
depending on when they leave terminus or
escape terminus I think they're gonna
head to Alexandria for the people that
haven't read the comic that's basically
Washington DC that thing that we saw on
Beth's spoon in that Daryl episode it's
also the place where Abraham was trying
to get Eugene to based on a lot of the
stuff that's being filmed right now and
stuff that people have been posting to
Facebook it seems like they're not gonna
get there for a while so I'm hoping that
season six turns into the journey to
Alexandria Andrew J West's character
Gareth this guy is a series regular this
year
meaning he's in most of the episodes I'm
hoping that means that they spend a
large portion of the season at terminus
they're only about halfway through
filming this series so as they post new
images if things are implied that
they're gonna get anywhere specific I'll
try and say in a video question number
three KJ asks what did you think about
Aisha Tyler's comments about Beth
becoming Gareth's terminus Queen so I
totally didn't believe that but I did
think it was a funny way to think about
Beth she's supposed to get a lot more
mature this season but the only thing we
know about her specifically is that
she's gonna get her own story like the
governor did in season four there's
gonna be like a Beth episode that tells
the story of what happened to her right
after she got kidnapped most of the
rumors I've seen say her story this
season will mostly take place away from
the survivors I do think they're gonna
be reunited eventually but it's fun to
think about a scenario whereby Beth
helps them escape
I don't know necessarily that's what's
gonna happen though question number four
ash asks do you have a theory on how
Carol and Tyreese learn about Rick and
the group being trapped and do you think
it'll be an emotional reunion so I think
that they're gonna arrive at terminus
like right as rick's group is getting
stuffed in that train car I'm hoping
it's like a situation where they get to
the fence line and see Garrett's men
with guns on Rick as they're getting
stuffed into the car or it could be like
a situation where they hit the fence and
they see something funky going on
unrelated to Rick's group and they just
figure it out that the terminus is a bad
place I don't think that'll just waltz
in the front gate and be dumped in the
train car like everyone else but as for
the reunion if they do end up going
inside terminus yes Rick is probably
gonna have a major joy attack when he
sees Judith I feel like him seeing
Judith inside terminus would be
something that would set him off like it
would cause him to go crazy on all the
terminus people question number five
Rose asks do you think that Daryl will
be happy to see that Beth is alive when
and if they meet up with everyone again
I don't think that Daryl is gonna see
Beth anytime soon but I think it's just
gonna be like Rick seeing Judith again
Beth is very precious to Daryl they had
that life-changing field trip together I
think she really brought him back from
the dead emotionally speaking I know
there were a lot of people talking about
an implied ship between the two of them
like something deeper I don't think that
was going on I think that he just has a
really soft spot for her question number
six galaxy ronan asks if they're doing
flashbacks to this season do you think
the characters from the first two
seasons who died might make an
appearance
I wonder if you're asking about the
Morales family they're actually not
confirmed dead they're just like a live
floating around somewhere
a lot of people were hoping that they'd
come back in the season 3 finale but
never did I definitely think that
they'll be doing more flashbacks but
usually they're just to tell character
backstories or deal with periods of time
the show did not include it's like at
the end of season 4 when we had that
flashback to the prison that took place
between the season 3 finale and the
season 4 premiere it was just like a
period of time that the show didn't do I
think if they end up doing non character
specific flashbacks like group
flashbacks again it'll be from between
seasons mostly I'm just expecting to see
more characters backstories like when we
got me shown flashbacks last season
question number 7 David asks do you
think that anyone is gonna buy into
Gareth's new way of life that they
teased I would be so disappointed if one
of the survivors didn't accidentally eat
some of the meat off that grill it'd be
pretty funny in like a horrifying way I
don't think that we're gonna see any
brainwashed survivors I don't think that
the new Rick would let that happen to
anyone but just looking at the people in
this train car I don't think that any of
them are so empty-headed that they let
Gareth fill them with ideas so whenever
Andrew J Wes was teasing Garrett's
philosophy and that interview that he
did he made it sound like the show was
gonna treat it as like a really big deal
so I think that the show's gonna tease
us and make us think that some of the
characters won't drink the kool-aid but
in the end I don't think that any of
them are gonna go to the dark side I am
really curious to see what ends up
happening to Garrett's character at the
end of this season question number 8
Fabian asks how much time will the
survivor spend at terminus the whole
season or just half of it so whenever
Andrew West character was named as
series regular for season 5 I thought
that they meant they'd be spending a ton
of time there but based on some of the
images that I've seen recently
it makes me think something a little bit
different most of the behind-the-scenes
images that are being posted from
production now or from other places like
out in the world in terms of production
status I think they're about halfway
done filming episodes Norman Reedus
posted this picture saying day 1 at the
beginning of maze so based on a
production schedule of like 6 to 8
episodes per week like that's what it
takes for them to get through filming an
episode I think they're at least about
halfway through all the episodes this
season there's been a lot of spoilery
images of survivors doing things on
different sets I'm not gonna post any of
those pictures here just because they
are kind of spoilery but
right now I'm gonna say that you know
midseason finale they'll probably be out
of terminus they could totally get out
before then but whatever they do I think
it's gonna be with tons of explosions
and tons of walkers question number nine
antsy asks what do you think caused
Glenn & Maggie's group to get put in the
train car yeah they didn't really answer
that in the special they just kind of
danced over the question I think that
they just did something like Rick's
group like Maggie flipped out and saw
something fishy and pull the gun
Glenn is just as quick to action but of
all the people in their group I think
that Maggie would be the first one to go
crazy on a termite question number 10
Castiel asks if Beth is with father
Gabriel do you think that those two will
head to terminus or will they do like a
Beth Father Gabriel episode like they
did at the end of season 4 so I assume
you're talking about like the governor
episode where they did the back story
yes I think that she's gonna be with
Seth Gilliam's character and if he does
turn out to be father Gabriel he's gonna
take her to his church like I said
they're gonna tell a Beth story in its
own episode just like the governor got
were they told what happened to him
after Woodbury there's been no
indication that Beth's character is
heading back to terminus so I can't
really confirm when she's gonna reunite
with any of the survivors question
number 11 John asks do you prefer the
comic or the show so there's actually
still a lot of the comic that I haven't
read yet I only try to stay like where
we are in the show so I try not to get
too far ahead I haven't really read
all-out war or a new beginning yet I
guess that means I prefer the show I
started watching the show before I
started reading the comic it's a big
difference in say the way I experience a
show like Game of Thrones where I have
read everything that's happened so far
so I'm wait for their head than the
actual show question number 12 Nathan
asks hey Charlie who do you think will
be the first survivor in Rick's group to
bite the dust this season so there been
a lot of Glenn rumors but based on you
know how much they've been able to
stretch out the plot from the comics I
think it's possible that they could go
all season without killing anyone
AMC has no reason whatsoever to kill
them off and they can always demand that
Scott can't both keep them alive if they
really wanted to just to be clear though
I don't think that they would demand
that a character not be killed
eventually I do think someone has to die
they have to kill someone at some point
but it could be like the season 5 finale
before we see that question number 13
Code Red asks do you think another group
may rescue the survivors such as the
hilltop or the kingdom
so I don't think we're gonna see anyone
from the kingdom for anyone that hasn't
read the comic that's basically the
people near Washington DC that's like a
school near Washington DC so that's way
farther away that's in like issue 100
when that shows up and we're in like
issue 60 where the show is right now I
think if they get any outside help it'll
be from the other survivors like Carol
and Tyreese or Morgan will reappear
mostly I think that their escape will be
because of something that they do the
survivors inside terminus I don't think
it'll be like a Dave's ex machinist
situation there is that Walker parade
that's gonna get there eventually but I
don't think that's gonna be the direct
cause of their escape I think it's just
gonna help create a distraction for the
terminus people question number 14
nicolas asks do you ever think that
morgan will come back so Scott Gimple
did say that he would come back
eventually and whenever he was talking
about it it was during season four he
was like you know he's not coming back
this season but definitely in the future
technically it's the future now but I'm
starting to think that if we do see him
it will be it like another big location
like Alexandria so it could even be like
season six before we see him again
but we will see him again question
number 15 Daniel asks if everyone is
infected with the virus how come people
that get bitten turn way faster so the
walkers have like all this crazy
bacteria growing in their mouths
whenever someone gets bitten they get
infected with that crazy bacteria and it
causes all kinds of crazy infections
that shuts down people's immune systems
way faster so it's not so much about
getting bitten by Walker
it's about getting infected with all
that extra bacteria question number 16
and last one mess monster asks for the
last 16 episodes in season four it was
all about can you come back from doing
terrible things and now that we're in
season five what do you think this
seasons gonna be about so thematically
they just kind of explained that it's
about doing what it takes to survive
you know rising to the challenge like
are you willing to do what it takes do
you have it inside of you that's where
you get to talk about people who are not
badasses becoming badasses there are so
many awful things that I'm looking
forward to seeing Rick and the other
survivors do this season it's gonna be
so much fun it's a very action based
maybe in one of my future bonus videos
I'll do like a video for the top ten
most badass things that the survivors
have done so far
thank you so much for so many questions
these Q&A videos always a ton of fun to
do remember check the description for
more Walking Dead links and important
dates but my next bonus video will
probably be a Comic Con explainer so be
sure to subscribe to get that I'm really
looking forward to doing that and
there's also gonna be special giveaway
so right now you can click here to learn
about what went down with all that new
footage and you can click here to learn
about the new characters coming to
season 5 thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tonight
high fives